♪
>> Harold: BIG CITIES
STRUGGLING TO DEAL WITH
LAWLESSNESS OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO
SHOWING CHILDREN FORCED TO
NAVIGATE THEIR WAY THROUGH
HOMELESS PEOPLE DOING DRUGS
AFTER GETTING OFF THE SCHOOL
BUS.
IN LOS ANGELES OLYMPIC MEDALIST
KIM GLASS ALMOST BLINDED AND
LEFT WITH MULTIPLE FACIAL
FRACTURES AFTER SHE WAS HIT WITH
A METAL PIPE BY A HOMELESS
PERSON.
>> BEFORE I KNEW IT A BIG METAL
PIPE HIT ME RIGHT HERE, HERE.
IT HAPPENED SO FAST.
HE CLEARLY SWUNG IT FROM THE
STREET, SO HE WAS NOT EVEN CLOSE
TO ME AT ALL.
AND TOOK ME DOWN, AND NOW
THERE'S A LOT OF MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE ON THE STREETS RIGHT NOW,
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO BE FEARFUL
WHEN WE WALK, BUT YOU DO.
JUST BE SAFE.
>> Harold: THE STORIES ARE
DISTURBING, NOT JUST IN
LOS ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO,
BUT TELLING THE STORY OVER THE
LAST FEW DAYS IN TELEVISION,
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THIS?
>> Dana: I AM DEVASTATED FOR
HER AND I AM THANKFUL THAT SHE
WAS WILLING TO --
SHE IS A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN WHO IS
GOING TO SAY HERE IS WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME.
AND SHE IS DESPONDENT OVER IT IN
TERMS OF WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
OUR CITY.
SO BECAUSE OF THE STORIES, THEY
ARE SO MANY OF THEM, YEAH, A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE FEELING THIS WAY I
THINK.
AND WHAT I THOUGHT WAS JUST
INCREDIBLE IS THAT VIDEO OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO KIDS HAVING TO
WALK THROUGH THE DRUG DEN LOOKS
LIKE A MOVIE SET.
PLAYING THAT ON A LOOP OVER AND
OVER.
AND WHERE'S GAVIN NEWSOM?
>> Judge Jeanine: ABSOLUTELY.
>> Dana: WHEN THIS IS
HAPPENING UNDER HIS NOSE, THAT'S
YOUR HOMETOWN.
HE WANTS TO RUN AGAINST --
OKAY.
>> Greg: TELLING PEOPLE TO
LEAVE FLORIDA TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA.
>> Dana: AND I ADMIRE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE PUTTING UP THE
VIDEOS, MAKING IT MORE REAL AND
MORE LIKELY, HOPEFULLY THAT WE
WILL LEARN ABOUT IT.
>> Harold: GREG, YOU TALKED A
LOT ABOUT --
>> Greg: YES, WE ALL DO.
>> Harold: YOU TALK A LOT OF
TIMES.
BUT LISTEN, YOU TALK A LOT ABOUT
THE NEED FOR MENTAL INSTITUTIONS
AND HEALTH INSTITUTIONS,
ARRESTING THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMMITTING THESE TYPES OF
CRIMES, THEY NEED TO BE IN A
MENTAL INSTITUTION NOR FAKE J.LO
ARE JUST SOME HYBRID?
HOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT IT?
>> Greg: HONESTLY THEY NEED TO
BE COMPELLED TO BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED.
AND WE HAVE ADVOCATED THAT WITH
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE SOMEHOW BELIEVE THAT IT'S
SOMEONE'S RIGHT TO BE A HARM TO
OTHERS IN A HARM TO THEMSELVES.
WE DID NOT USED TO THINK THAT
WAY, THAT CHANGED IN THE 60s
AND INCIDENTS WITH WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE ATHLETES THEY WOULD
CAPTIVATE CHANGE SOCIETY.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE BURNING GETS
MOMENT AND THE UTAH TOURIST THAT
WAS KILLED IN NEW YORK.
BUT I THINK THAT THE MEDIA
DECIDES THAT UNLESS YOU CONTAIN
THE VIOLENCE FOR TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S IT'S REALLY NOT THAT
EXCITING TO THEM AND THIS STUFF
IS JUST, OH, THAT'S JUST ANOTHER
THING.
IT WILL GO AWAY.
WE NEED TO TOUCH ON, I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU GUYS DID IT
YESTERDAY WITH THE CHILDREN, BUT
THE REAL UGLINESS IS AGAINST
WOMEN.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IT'S
LIKE, WHERE THE FEMINISTS?
YOU KNOW, YOUR GENDER IS GETTING
ITS KICKED ON THE STREETS IN
SPORTS AND IN DICTIONARIES, SO
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
NOTHING.
>> Harold: YOUR HONOR?
>> Judge Jeanine: I THINK THE
SADDEST PART OF THE STORY AS THE
KIDS THAT HAVE TO SEE THAT.
THEY HAVE TO WITNESS AND SEE
PEOPLE SHOOTING UP, BUYING
DRUGS, MAY BE DEAD ON THE STREET
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHEN DANA HAS
ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, THIS GUY
WANTS TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT WHEN
HE HAS A CITY THAT IS A MESS
LIKE THAT AND CALIFORNIA, THIS
KIM GLASS, SHE IS GORGEOUS,
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
WHAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING NOW IS
JUST A BASIC TAKEDOWN OF AMERICA
WHERE A LAW AND ORDER DOES NOT
MATTER ANYMORE.
AND WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IN
SAN FRANCISCO AS THEY NOW WANT
TO HAVE COMMUNITY PEOPLE AND NOT
POLICE RESPOND TO LOW-LEVEL
CALLS REGARDING EMERGENCY CALLS
WITH THE HOMELESS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
GOING AND GETTING HIT WITH THAT
METAL PIPE AND THEN SHOOTING UP
WITH WHO HAS DIRTY NEEDLES IN
THE COMMUNITY WORKER TO GO IN
THAT IS NOT A COP?
WE ARE JUST ASKING FOR IT TO GET
WORSE.
AND IT'S JUST HORRIBLE.
AND BY THE WAY, RIGHT NOW I JUST
WANT TO SAY ONE MORE THING, NOW
THAT ALAN GREG IS TALKING ABOUT
LETTING THE BODEGA OR OWNER WITH
THE DISMISSED CHARGES, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS TAKING HIM SO LONG?
BOTH GUYS ARE MAKING DECISIONS,
BUT THEY HAVE MADE A DECISION
THAT HE'S NOT GOING TO CHARGE
THE WOMAN WHO STARTED THE WHOLE
THING WHO WAS FURIOUS, WHO WENT
HOME AND GOT HER BOYFRIEND, AND
THE OWNER OF THE BODEGA WAS RUDE
TO HER AND THREE TIMES THAT'S AN
ASSAULT IN THE SECOND DEGREE IN
NEW YORK AND THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO CHARGE HIM.
I MEAN, THERE IS VIOLENT CRIME
GOING ON AND PEOPLE ARE JUST
ACCEPTING IT.
>> Greg: SHE IS A WIDOW NOW.
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T
THINK THEY WERE MARRIED.
>> Harold: I WILL COME TO
JESSE WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT HOW
THEY ARE RENAMING SCHOOLS.
>> Dana: $500,000 AND
BASICALLY DESTROYED A MURAL OF
GEORGE WASHINGTON.
LIKE MAYBE BUY SOME BOOKS OR FIX
YOUR CIRCULATION.
>> Harold: OR GET THE HOMELESS
OFF THE STREETS.
>> Jesse: I'M SORRY, YOU CAN
NEVER LISTEN TO WHAT A LIBERAL
SAYS.
THEY SAY THAT THEY CARE, THEY
SAY THAT TODAY ARE GOING TO GIVE
YOU FREE COLLEGE, THEY ARE GOING
TO GIVE YOU YOUR KID FREE DAY
CARE, THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU
FREE HEALTH CARE.
THEIR ENTIRE GOVERNING
PHILOSOPHY AS WE ARE GOING TO
HELP PEOPLE AND PROVIDE A SAFETY
NET.
DO THEY EVER HELP A HOMELESS
PERSON?
THEY DON'T EVEN TALK ABOUT THEM.
THEY LET THEM FESTER AND DECAY
IN FILTH AND DRUG ADDICTION AND
DIE IN THE STREETS.
AND THEY SAY THAT THEY CARE
ABOUT KIDS AND THEY HAVE KIDS
MARCHING OVER ZOMBIES TO SCHOOL.
THEY SAY THAT THEY CARE ABOUT
WOMEN, WHERE THEY GET SLAMMED IN
THE FACE WITH A PIPE, THEY DON'T
TALK ABOUT THAT.
THEY SAY THEY CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY LIBERALS I
KNOW THAT DON'T BUY CARBON CLOTH
SETS, OR TESLA'S COMING TO SEE
THEM LIVE IN MANHATTAN, JUST
THROW IT RIGHT THERE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
WATCH WHAT THEY D